snap what's up everybody welcome to the
live Q&A with hot boxing with Mike Tyson
I live in Britain this is Mike Tyson
well you got some we've got some Mike
[ __ ] - well welcome everybody thank
you guys so much thank you for
supporting us through season one Nelson
Mandela we'll take care of you in a
second freeing up the Mandela season two
is on its way we're very excited about
that thank you guys for tuning in we've
got a bunch of questions so Mike you
want any opening remarks this is
beautiful man with God here we are
Tyson ranch you got one point two
thousand peeps tuning in so so get him
out man for a live stream and it's
growing all right so the first question
is from Landon be what's up Landon Mike
in heaven what are you guys listening to
these days I'm listening to a lot of
podcasts I listen to some audio books
carlos castaneda have you ridden have
you heard of it no tell me he's written
a lot about shamanism especially dealing
with the peyote plant mezack alito and
his journeys with that plant medicine
what else
I listen to a lot of talks a lot of Alan
Watts I throw him on YouTube and I
listened to his conversations Harry -
and
no I'll just speaker yeah all right I'm
gonna have to check him out too so
that's what we're listening to Mike is
dead dive into Earl Nightingale another
speak yeah well it's good to prime the
mind with all that that's what they call
it mind stuff yeah yeah
the next question we've got here another
good one Mike and Evan what are your
favorite books from Dimitri d what's
your favorite book Makaveli the print
yeah you can go with that guy named the
guy that wrote Candide Voltaire those
guy that you want to go from a classic
perspective or if you want to go to like
modern-day stuff um vividly some good
stuff um what's your favorite viagra or
ya biography or book on Alexander the
Great is there one you could point to
for a history of that era that just he's
over this mystery area was his name he
wrote about that man that blue top blue
top
he thought about that down yeah
absolutely my favorite books be here now
by Ram Dass it's a great book it's a guy
who was Purpose Driven Life another
great book another one of my favorite
books about specifically about ayahuasca
and shamans down in Peru is called the
cosmic serpent if you're interested in
the plant medicines that's a great one
to dive into to give you a good overview
of plant medicine and the spiritual path
from that perspective
moving on good question here from Daniel
a what's the one piece of information
Mike that everyone should know be kind
to one another and respect no no doubt
about lady should bully anybody
emotionally or anything because they can
I don't think it could be any better
than that I think that's when you
distill it all down that's the quality
you don't have to be no smile but
respect do you have any thoughts on how
someone can do that say somebody's
really [ __ ] angry somebody's really
just angry at the world that themselves
they hate themselves how does somebody
come from a megalomaniac espect eveni
things about me me me is about what if
it wasn't self-love is about everyone
else yeah that's the paradox
yeah well just to reiterate in case you
guys missed any piece of that at all
it's an inside job those Mike just said
self-love leads to loving everyone else
loving the people around you letting go
of self hate allows you to let go of the
anger and hate you have for the world
around you my Cuban that next one I
don't have anything to add to that
that's just you know that's as good as
it gets there from Craig are I like hope
you are well
what's up Craig my question would be do
you think professor
athletes should be able to use cannabis
as a way to heal the body and relax
after a fight or match I'm only talking
I'm Greg from my experience only I think
it's a good idea I think it's really a
good idea but there is a healing process
that you have to go to I you smoke pot a
cannabis constantly I ink onto
unconsciously it's that period that we
go to the healing period pot the mind
and pot and then my intertwine another
yeah absolutely well the chemical
compounds found in this plant are
naturally occurring in our bodies and
are a key part of our healing process
scientifically that's proven that's not
just some mumbo jumbo or some hippy idea
that's real science set as that cannabis
as the chemical compounds cannabinoids
that are found in the plant help our
bodies heal after trauma they help us
deal with stress they help alleviate
pain so it's very important in our
healing process and recovery especially
for athletes so how will they know how
to get him the treatment of training
many smokers yeah I never smoke I would
never train I would never train I smoke
I'll be a puppy it's over we Pig it's
great don't you feel like it just gets
you in tune with your body and gives me
in tune with the world with the world
yeah with your environment absolutely I
said that said that myself oh good
question here from miles what are you
guys looking to achieve with this
podcast this podcast is just for
awareness yeah and but for their witness
of me for their awareness of you for the
winner for what the awareness of what we
Hanwha chapters on yeah our episodes on
you know it's all about awareness in our
nation absolutely no one's trying to
show that we're smarter than anyone else
we will alternate learn together yeah he
might the job it's definitely for
awareness to wake people up it's to show
you that there's others out there who
may have been through some really
difficult times and when you're able to
just take one more step get back up on
the horse
and continue on that journey I'm trying
to find your life purpose that's a
little bit on the air for with you who
are we where do we come we really just I
mother and father's children mm-hmm yeah
what do you think your life purpose is
right now though
excuse me what do you believe your
life's purpose is right now to be the
best money technical possibility hmm and
I'll be the best my path and I possibly
be it will have to be a serious change I
wouldn't see the word Nick I always just
be a pig my whole life will be so change
right with the best I possibly and I'm
afraid to be the best in the least of
mine yeah anything that whoa
that alone is just Wow how do you feel
about cursing huh
you feel like cursing is something to
rid yourself of no it's what I think
about good I think anybody should be
allowed to curse in the bad no cursing
is I don't feel right when I could even
the one I curse interesting something
about it
right you don't like it yeah yeah
interesting
you know Tony Robbins says that he uses
curse words to like wake people up man
he concurs yeah yeah and I think I think
that is a great use of it no you can
curse yeah
don't you think that's a great use of
their now listen there's nothing gonna
strike you to stand to command like
curse words yeah yeah get your
[ __ ] ass up oh yeah bro for
sure I've heard that a thousand times
definitely definitely let's see we got
ooh
all right from the Jose from Jose
Leopold's a shout-out to Jose great
question Mike what do you believe life
is likely them life is a party a joke
yeah yeah yeah you know Paul I think
it's the pause somewhere - it is monks
are hiding out and and every one of the
huts they have a skull of a head and
yeah it's gonna fit mostly laughing
because there's like the joke scallop
bone yeah spirit is just floating around
somewhere yeah I know you've had these
moments and these insights word you
think you're all wrapped up in some
thing you're all wrapped up in some
problem some situation some fight you
and your wife had something that you did
you said to your kid and you feel bad
about it and then all of a sudden you
like go all the way down to the end and
you laugh because you're like this is
all meaningless listen
this is what I've learned since I've
been on this um Enlightenment trail or
whatever right I realized that this is
our outer world and this is our in the
world we mustn't allow out of the world
the distractor in the world
hmm we can play without oil but don't
take it serious where it distracts the
end the world I meet the inner world
uncomfortable and worried and scared
you can catch agents and diseases and
stuff so don't let this or this world
isn't meant to destroy this world
mmm let this world into this world
that's it son I found that recently
that's a great was trying to antagonize
you may wait a year maybe two years yeah
it's waiting to attack am i you yeah
yeah either blow yeah it's so true
that's a great insight nothing Tampa's
with the inner world the other world
entertainment only don't take it serious
I'm talking what you children your
family your wife your mother your father
did outer world don't let them affect
the in the world it's true though I
remember thinking that when I was a
little kid there were times when you
know I had coaches I had teachers I had
family members who were really hard on
me and spoke really harshly to me and I
took it all on you know for a long time
in my football career as an athlete I
think we take on a lot of our coaching
you know and as we're molding ourselves
into that greatest version of ourselves
that's the champion and it took me a
long time to release myself from a lot
of that because it put a lot of scars
you know yeah
well they're really fragile mind the
fragile yeah yeah minds tell the things
that we will overtly notice for lying to
see why they're saying that to us
yeah why the famous [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] yes it though I know it takes a
long time to realize that and a lot of
that I believe is from the people around
us who have said things critical or
judging look like a mother yeah our
mothers yes of course the people that
were the most important to us when we
were in the purest stage of our
existence you know it's that one thing
that's really amazing to me about kids
is how pure their minds are and how
crucial that is you know as children you
know you come in to levy neat wink wink
responsibly drink baby the CBD beverage
you know as children we don't know
anything yeah we don't know any members
what other people other people did or
what my mother told me I mean I remember
my mother telling me there's good people
in black and white because bad people in
black and white and the only thing yes
ma'am no no sir and that kind of stuff
it was all about improving yourself at
the person cuz we're so poor so he
always when the fat man is to be kind
they wanted to stand out my family's
known for standing out being polite and
stuff well I mean that goes with
respecting everyone you know and just
were and we'll look at you man look at
where you've gone in life who you are
what you've done and how far that simply
acts you know how far that continued
disrespecting people being kind to
others absolutely
I used to always think my life is fair
coming from Brownsville Brooklyn you
think it's all about fear I won't be
fear I want to be loved you know yeah
it's more it's more scarier to be loved
and to be feared you know you know the
obligation to love we all know the
obligation to fear but do you know the
obligation to love Wow scarier the fear
than me buddy hmm what love is to love
the essence of love I don't know what
the word but the essence of love of who
meaningless sake is total dedication
it's your total dedication
[Music]
all right
all right no none of those questions are
any good all right here we go
Jared hey what's up John I've heard Mike
say in an interview once that not all
great men are good men and this led him
down a different path does he believe
good men can become great men also or do
you have to pick one does goodness make
you weak goodness can never make you
weak yeah if the people that if people
had a week when they receive goodness
hmm you know this is never weak but
goodness could weaken people yeah I love
it
here's a fun one you might hate it but
from Darren Darren since Mike if you
were still in your 20s do you think you
would have unified all the belts in
today's heavyweight division
oh listen I'm a twenty would you like me
at 20 years old there's no done yeah no
they're really good fighters and I
respect all this guilt it would have
been very tough fighting though yeah and
some great fighters would be like who
would you have been most worried I guess
about out of the top heavy weights right
now
Joshua Ruiz Wilder fury is there one of
those guys that you think would be a
toughest matchup for you if I was
training Joshua Joshua would be you know
was that his head no no he has doesn't
know
hmmm interesting don't you think having
ttan you have to know it that's the last
piece let me take that if a guy had the
end doesn't know it what comes yeah I
got it I got it doesn't have it but
doesn't know that he doesn't have it
it's going to do better than yeah it's
not a trip yeah yeah I totally know yeah
yeah
Ricardo release asks when and how did
Mike and Evan meet you talked about
yeah we've pretty much been this
partners we work together yeah
and same office pretty much yeah what
was it two years ago May of 2018 yeah
Mike was putting on a health summit the
Tyson holistic summit and he called me
in to help facilitate the event to put
together his presentation well I want to
do a great job for you man you did thank
you and Mike said it I did a hell of a
job he asked me to stick around and I
just kept showing up and then you know
next thing you know we're doing podcast
having a ball I got my brother from
another mother here you know all good
night yes sir
okay here we go moving on
Mike good question from Jose Oh Mike
what do you think of that well doc what
do you think about dreams dreams dreams
I think teams are beautiful
yeah dreams are a fascinating thing I
think dreams the information yeah we
could add a certain state in your life
you don't dream as much yeah interesting
do you dream anymore no no I'm gonna get
that remember now well I just started
dreaming again after years and uh and
it's really uh I feel like just really
grateful for the dreams good information
yeah explain something to me yeah and
it's interesting because how do we know
we're not dreaming right now
interpretation that you know I only
think I'm a dye animal wake up anyway
look around you we [ __ ] mother
yeah good there was a good question like
what was your favorite city to go to in
your 20s right that would be nice I
guess I'll a but Mandy thief some sleepy
Washington DC near 20th would know
because that'd be your first interaction
with elite black people being from
Africa Amelia venture that would be your
first [ __ ] engagement with bone black
people on top of their game
intellectually definitely socially
everything financially in that that's
awakening interested it's really on
humble income time when you think you're
a big shot you know interesting
yeah DC is all about power isn't man
politics man what do you think about
politics it's a game I have to be a game
it wouldn't be you know this intrigued
with it right to be a game so I have to
win some I have to lose yeah that's
fascinating
would you ever get into it now thank you
no not by choice
maybe the universe will take you there
bro ain't nobody you know who knows how
from Frank Frank Mac Frank Mac Frank
Mac Frankie Mac yep how do you keep your
ego in check by dying
oh no long existing who know I'll be
lying to you if I think I'd keep my ego
in check I got my ego in check no that's
not true the reason that I have this
company and this stuff is working out
because my ego got loose yeah that's a
tough one though and your ego is once
you create it it's not going anywhere
anyway it's a lifetime battle you know I
think what Mike said though is the core
essence of how you defeat your egos
through diet and you might mine it every
day you have to die a little and some
way you let things go letting things go
allowing pieces of yourself to die that
keeps your ego in check because your ego
wants to constantly hold on to things
hold on to your identity who you are
what you think you do how you make money
what matters in your world how
importantly you want to compete with
anybody I want you to compete with
everything and everybody your children
your wife yeah you part everybody and so
letting go constantly letting go [ __ ] at
the end of it you have to let go of
everything you know that's the Zen
his way he let go of everything you
detach from it all nothing matters
anymore and am i and that's a really
dark place to be - my son just when I we
don't control our ego pretty much I
guess we just you just don't respond to
it maybe I hit some respond to my ego
home challenge your own talk to eyes I
know this is [ __ ] I noticed that the
police see what's going on right now I
might be talked about it before but
everybody wants to hear you talk a
little bit about Tupac and they've only
got about five minutes so maybe if you
want to give them a quick little two
sentences or a few words on what made
Tupac so special and something you
really appreciated about him I think -
part was just an amazing person because
um he was just it was just different
three months the never stopped working
it was just so fast it was a different
personalities he's sweet and to let you
talking about you know Richard write the
book you know and bitching and parlin
and then they know he's activist you
have about an energy bar spirit a public
warrior with everything yeah he could
have been everything yeah yeah it was
time yeah you know you've had a bit of
time a little bit in the path - Oh
interesting
yeah in the path do you think when
someone like that comes into the world
they're almost so powerful they're
because he says just a manifestation of
everything that he is some people can
shut it all right they can't shut it off
like it's almost too much power for the
money and he can't shut it off
yeah amazing
he's I mean I listened to the all eyes
on me album literally every football
game at those before I would on the
field
will it make him think that head at old
it's all along pretty much his synopsis
was paranoia
please very market Machiavellian you
know he wrote of well there's all that
the Illuminati stuff but Makaveli knew
what he was writing was [ __ ] hmm-hmm
the prince and all that yeah
maybe thought the printing he was
improving yeah yeah alright we've got
about two minutes left
two minutes two [ __ ] minutes
oh they in a piggy I was on the internet
with me improving with - oh we gotta put
that up maybe and uh we can dip that up
on in Sturgeon never saw any pictures
like l1 and widows pictures Mike and
Tupac and prison Tupac came to visit
like and I was crazy
92 Wow right Wow alright how do you feel
about one more question
go for it dude this is our right now I
know I love it but Mike how do you deal
with fear see ya yep from
I don't know who said it I lost it but
it that was his question like how do you
deal with fear well this is why we're
not over the stages of my time on this
earth I learned to deal with it in
different variations pretty much you
know before I'm afraid I might get hurt
afraid to go to jail or die in this and
land and I think hey I'm a die anyway
so which is it my afraid that I might
die now on my diabaté there a piece of
what is that I'm afraid I might die now
or later sooner or later maybe that's it
I don't know what's happening I don't
know if I'm afraid to die because I
bagged a couple of times offer the told
and it was pretty cool and the last time
I died I was the best up with died died
in my life I want to die again there's a
great experience
yeah since you're putting it like that
so how do we even know it's bad I just
keep believing once we guys when we
start to live hmm why would God make us
to do that why would God make us food
that we no longer exist thanks for the
ride guys and pull no longer exist I
remember there's no more
and then just as black or it's lightly
it's nothing happens no more I
understand that you know God is smarter
than that and cotton don't do so he does
why would you want to hurt us it cause
what we think he is yeah it's my belief
that he is you know he's our Shepherd
isn't he pretty much really when we
think of God that way you don't know I'm
not going through a Jesus perspect I'm
you think for what a shepherd does he
looks over the flock you know so then
would you say because I would say this
that fear them is a manifestation of the
ego absolutely fear if the ego yes
fear the ego fear of change yes yes boom
[ __ ] that's a nugget fear is your ego
man alright guys well I know it's short
and sweet but hope you guys found that
interesting we'll definitely do it again
at some point
thank you guys so much for supporting us
through season one neither great peanut
look at me love you these are peanuts
buddy
like is snacking on peanuts I've been
smoking all day yeah dudes dudes fun I'm
on a diet and working he's got to get
some fuel his brains going man it needs
food time things feel wouldn't ever been
in a old existence absolutely that's
awesome look at you bro you look great
this is sharp is 170 pounds it's sharp
so thank you guys so much again from
both of us from everyone here at hotbox
of enticing rant we love you guys tons
season 2 is on its way
be patient lot of cool [ __ ] coming to
y'all the end of 2019 and 2020 look get
some really small people in here and
from le who the people who I'll get them
on the cat sure alright everybody
until next time I'm Evan Britain